what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get
our lunch money right i'm here with the
beautiful intelligent palina eva liva
marinova pompliano p-i-m-p
pam pam she's got the right uniform on i
do two up underneath here
you know black only that's all that is
worth wearing
don't forget that block five is now
sponsor of lunch money basically they
want you to get money get paid
this past monday was block fi monday
where you get your interest payment go
get an interest bearing account with
block fight you can earn up to eight
point six percent apy
in that interest bearing account i don't
know why there's horns going on but
maybe they're celebrating as well
they're telling you go get the blockfy
account
go to blockfly.com pomp go do your
research i'm an investor
on the board i'm a user i'm happy you'll
be happy go get a block by account
he's happy because he slept like 10
hours last night facts
facts i got a little sleep secret that
i'll be sending out to you guys soon i'm
testing it right now
a little got a little uh new equipment
for sleeping
all right what's what's up yes i just
said equipment for sleeping i know all
y'all like what does he just say i'll
let you know don't worry
soon bitcoin this morning i was awoken
by someone who was extremely extremely
happy
that bitcoin's new price is at
fifteen thousand it's dead
the having's not priced in what else
nonsense
are all the bears going to say let me
tell you about it it's going to zero
no it's not let me tell you about a bull
bitcoin bull
bull oh my okay a bowl
so this woman got elected in wyoming
uh what is wyoming i mean wyoming did i
say wyoming yeah
wyoming her name is cynthia loomis
people elected her to the u.s senate and
she's the first person in the senate i
think or the first member of congress is
upper chamber to own cryptocurrency
that's cool i don't know about that what
do you mean maybe she's only public one
yeah but i'm pretty sure that some other
people own uh
crypto maybe it's like a special part of
they said the upper
yeah i don't know what that means but
there's definitely other elected
officials in either the center of the
house that own crypto
this sounds like members of the house of
representatives including former chair
of the judiciary committee bob
goodlatte latte goodlatte have disclosed
owning crypto in the past but no u.s
senator has got it so a senator has him
but a house of representative has
cool look uh i'm a fan i think she's
gonna do a great job
long live the king of bitcoin let's go
to the moon
chapter am i am i the king of bitcoin no
you could be the queen
of uh our house okay go ahead what's
next
okay um so this morning my i was talking
to my family in bulgaria
and my aunt texted me and was like
what's going on with your election
and i was like i don't know do you know
she didn't know either so what do you
what do you know
we live in the greatest country in the
world the united states
the lighthouse of democracy and we don't
know
how many votes either candidate has we
don't know who our president is
we don't know who the president is going
to be we know the president is right now
we don't know who the president is going
to be
they're finding votes some of them are
good for trump some of them are good for
biden
but when i read headlines that say
another 25 000 votes are
found uh-uh that's not good
we could do all kinds of crazy stuff i
saw a clip of a guy yesterday
who was talking about he's i can order
dominoes on my phone he literally said
this i can order dominoes on my phone
and i
and it will show me where it is in the
process
yet we can't count the votes for who is
going to be the president
this is madness this is stupid it is
very obvious
we need to fix the way that voting is
done
there's both the electoral college and
popular vote nonsense that probably
needs to be looked at
but more so we need to have a technology
enabled way to vote so that we're not
literally counting pieces of paper
by hand like we're living in 1847
and we're literally riding with feathers
and ink on the paper if he has equipment
to sleep
that tracks to sleep we can have a
better way to counter i got equipment to
sleep and y'all are literally counting
pieces of paper trying to figure out
there's literally a thing where if the
machine is reading some of them
and all of a sudden the machine can't
figure it out it hands it to a human and
the human tries to figure out the
voter's intent what
this is wild it's crazy it has nothing
to do with republican democrat
independent anything
it's just the process is super
antiquated and we need to fix it
that's all i'm gonna say stop counting
pieces of paper by hand by humans
it introduces the pers uh perception
that there could be manipulation even if
there is none right people don't like
the fact that
humans can do something and then on top
of that
it's 48 hours i've slept twice since we
voted
what's up my worst fear is voting for
someone and someone
misreading my intent just like how he
doesn't like it when i try to read his
intent he's like that ain't my intent
and i'm like that's definitely your
intent
okay ready that was bait i ain't taking
good
it was a quiet election night new york
city if you're in new york city you saw
that these businesses were preparing for
like armageddon
they were boarding up it was just
they were expecting chaos there have
been some demonstrations which
have been largely peaceful although
police say more
than 50 people were arrested including a
woman who was seen calling a
nypd officer a fascist and spitting on
him
but there were no reports of widespread
destruction that many stores across the
five boroughs
with boarded up windows expected i saw
the video
oh i did not see the video i don't want
to see the video the woman is standing
in front of a
cop standing there and she's screaming
at him and she keeps screaming at him
keep screaming up and it looks like she
spits on him like three or four
times like right in his face just spits
right on
you're lucky she's lucky no she's lucky
she lives in the united states because
you know what they did they grabbed her
and they arrested her
but in any other country in the world
for the most part they would have
whooped her
ass that's what would have happened i
don't know and so we
you walk up anybody who lives in another
country walk up to a cop and spit in
their face and see what happens
they're not gonna do what they did here
in the united states that's first of all
second of all this is a direct example
of what i was talking about yesterday
we're all in this together this woman is
no different she goes to her job
every day and just wants to go home and
live a happy life
that police officer i'm sure i don't
know who he was
but majority of those cops they want to
go to work do their job and go home
this whole idea of us first them all
this not it's all nonsense
we have to work together and it's
disgusting when we see stuff like that
and by the way
it's disgusting when we see cops do dumb
[ __ ] too the nypd
tweeted actions like this will not be
tolerated agitators who commit these
acts will be arrested
so anthony yesterday i listened in on a
very
interesting conversation he had coming
soon to the podcast do you want to tell
the people
there's a woman eliza orleans who's
running for the manhattan district
attorney
she's been a public defender for the
last like 10 12 years
and we did a two plus hour
conversation about the criminal justice
system
how it works what's broken how we could
potentially fix it what are the
misconceptions
all this stuff absolutely fascinating i
think i'm gonna release it on monday
uh when you listen to this conversation
you will be blown away by some of the
nonsense that goes on
uh some of it is intentional some of it
is just a byproduct of the system
but what is very clear is that cops deal
with a lot of [ __ ]
and literally the last thing that we
should be doing is going and standing in
front of a cop screaming at them and
then spitting in their face
because by the way if the cop did that
to that woman
she'd be all over the news saying how
she was assaulted by the cops the cops
are disgusting blah blah whatever
so the point is we are no better than
the police
the police are no better than us it was
a good conversation
it'll be out on monday what's next i
hate people
who just go and stand in front of
somebody like that and they're it's like
the kid in in high school
who's like you can't hit me you can't
hit me you can't hit me you can't hit
because the tees are standing right
there
guess what usually happens they hit the
kid
that's what happens in the real world
you can't do that stuff
go ahead but you can peacefully protest
you can peacefully protest but spitting
on a cop is not peacefully protesting
i'm all listen i'm all about protest you
guys want to go protest
knock yourselves out right there's a lot
of bad [ __ ] that goes on
there's a lot of accountability that
needs to happen there needs to be uh
somebody who is always there making sure
that the police serve the role that
they're supposed to
serve and they don't overstep their
bounds but at the same time you can't
say
hey we're mad because you're treating
people unfairly you're doing blah blah
whatever
and then turn around do the same thing
and this protest was not
i don't think about the police i think
it was about
it was just a peaceful demonstration for
count the votes
um i don't know why that happened or how
the police of course
okay what's next uber and lyft got their
way in california which
voters supporting their proposition 20
wait what
with voters supporting their proposition
22 ballot measure
prop 22 will exempt these and other gig
economy companies from a law that would
have forced them to treat drivers and
delivery workers as employees
instead they will be able to continue
treating them as independent contractors
saying the company's
saying the company's money okay
whoever writes these articles like dude
long story short
is that uber and lyft were facing a law
that uh
an absolute idiot an idiot the people
voted yeah the people voted but the
idiot who tried to come up with this law
right was trying to say that they're
employees they're obviously not
employees they're contractors
it's not that hard if you want to
provide more protections for them great
like we've talked about previously
i once said that they weren't to be
classified as employees and two i said
that what we should do is
we should have contractors we should
have employees and then literally create
a third category for
gig workers or on-demand workers or
whatever that's fine you can say that we
need to do something
for them more than contractors but
trying to take them out of the
contractor bucket and put them in the
employee bucket
is stupid yeah and the voters who are
usually pretty smart
said no this is stupid we're not going
to be yeah and the companies have
claimed that this
is a measure that many of their own
drivers and delivery workers support
but nobody believed them until the
well the best tweet i saw i forget who
said god i came right i think you might
have been in the ball maybe they've all
retweeted it
uh was if uber and lyft
can change the public perception and
defeat this
imagine what twitter facebook and google
can do on antitrust
i don't know okay
facebook's whatsapp on thursday announce
that it's rolling out a new feature that
will let users choose to automatically
delete
messages after seven days it's another
example facebook trying to improve
privacy and its products
what i mean sure
but like it's being saved somewhere in
servers right or does it
for seven days i mean at the end of the
day they just need end-to-end encryption
where facebook can't read the messages
like signal yeah like that that is what
needs to happen
and if it happens great their privacy
first if it doesn't then anything else
is just
uh security theater right or privacy
theater
yeah it's just like oh yeah you could
delete the messages after seven days
after we've read them for seven days
like what
and by the way i'm a fan i love facebook
i love people that work there
i think that they generally like are uh
trying to do the right thing but the
right thing here is end-to-end
encryption
yeah so guess what this we're moving on
to tick-tock guess what the most
popular thing on tick tock is that
people watch youtube videos
what no youtube videos no what how-to
videos
so people go on tick-tock some of the
most popular content
um has been tick tock oh wait no
oh never mind the most popular how-to
stuff is on youtube
but tick-tock is getting in on the
action and
after launching a dedicated learn on
tick-tock hashtag
earlier this summer with a slate of
premium creators producing videos for it
multiple users and social media watchers
are reporting sightings of a
new menu item called learn
it might not be the articles that are
wrong she might be reading them a little
weird
like this idea i like it too lots of
learning lots of learning
i like learning so do i i'm gonna learn
how to
uh never mind i'm not gonna say that one
go ahead um that was date two i was a
trap that i almost walked in so i have a
kind of an inappropriate joke today
we'll see what is a presidential
candidate who can't get his votes up
suffer from
what
dysfunction that's pretty good
it's not like i'm not gonna laugh but it
gotta smirk like you're on the smurfs oh
so stunning that's fine i like that one
i think we have to go because we have a
plumbing issue and then everything's
flooded and like there's water
everywhere and i don't know what's going
on i can't turn on the dishwasher
user error no no yesterday i got mad at
him because i was like swimming in water
trying to clean it he's over there like
why won't my little video upload oh
nobody cares about your little video
who claimed it swimming pool that's
because i asked you to
kindly who cleaned it no but i cleaned
the beginning of it who cleaned it
who cleaned it was a drawing effort who
cleaned it
what do you mean by cleaned it you just
put
the sink was linking and i literally i
was like drinking it basically it was
like i was like an elephant
at the uh at a reservoir in the desert
and i was so parched that i had to drink
it all up
that's disgusting that's it for lunch
money we'll see you guys tomorrow i got
issues to deal with see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends